sophie uh there's not much to say about
this game what just happened
oh um
yeah like this opening uh was
something that
i guess i don't play that much but
i thought i would give it a try for this
game you wanted to surprise her early on
in the opening and you definitely did
she played this move knight f to d7 what
were your feelings when you realize that
you can just simply take on d5 and
pretty much get an objectively winning
position
um
yeah i like looked at this um before the
game um
like i think that
um there's even like a different trap
with like bishop b7 e4
and then knight b to d7 which is like
i also looked at with like then there's
knight takes c6
like bb7 and now knight takes c6 yeah so
like there's all kinds like this is a
really tricky opening in general i think
um and like knight fc7 makes sense if
you don't see that like uh then d6 yeah
yeah
um very nice so they're like lots of
different tricks to this opening um
yeah so i
wasn't really like expecting that after
you have it but i thought there was like
a
pretty i thought there was like a slim
chance that could happen because it it
does make sense like if you don't cc
takes d5 and i take c5 um
and you played it fast you knew uh what
was happening right now you knew the
assessment of this position
now
what are the thoughts that go through
your mind at this point with this
victory you guarantee yourself a tie
break at least
what are your thoughts about that
um i'm definitely a little relieved
because i was super nervous after like i
lost the last um last round and
yeah i was definitely like yeah just
really jittery and i just
cause because at that point like i mean
i i still had like
a pretty safe one-point lead but like i
it wasn't as safe as two points
you're definitely not so like i knew
like i had to do well in the next you
know few games so
now we were having this discussion on
the panel how did you approach this game
did you see this as an almost must-win
situation for yourself given that
anne marie valia was quite struggling in
this event yeah i thought like
i like my best chances definitely come
if i win this game
because you have three suitors that are
chasing you closely uh behind did you
get a chance to check any of those games
um
not that much
probably not that much because not that
much happened in those ones you finished
in under an hour this might be the
quickest decisive game that we see here
at the juniors congratulations sophie
tomorrow still one more game to play but
we'll let you go get some rest and i'm
sure you will be getting your popcorn
ready and watching the games of your
closest competitors congratulations
sophie thank you